I definitely have a very different  perspective than a lot of men because I  you know I got a closer look at women  for many years mhm  I don't I don't think I understand women  particularly better than then I was  gonna that was my yes question I don't  yeah I don't think I don't not the  emotional side that meant that we don't  get that we were just like scared of and  we don't get in like no I really don't I  never had that  even before would find myself in  relationships you know doing something  that I had no idea what I'd done that  really upset my girlfriend and I didn't  know why in the in the same way that men  do where are they now all new Saturday  10/9 central